um what is that call when you have eggs
and there's on a ham and there's like a
little muffin
what is that it's beautiful what is that
I love it when I'm at breakfast and I
get that sometimes I don't get it a lot
I don't get it that often but every now
and I look I read it though when I see
it on the menu I'll be like hmm I'd love
to have it but but I'm not gonna you
know it seemed like something you get if
you just want a prize or something well
you they then you can get that but if
you're just kind of you know not winning
prizes and just kind of live in life and
just then you don't I feel like you
don't get it and so that's how that's
kind of what I do I get you know I don't
get it but I read it I look around I ask
anybody else if they're gonna get it too
I say oh you're gonna get it mom or you
you know
hey cuz are you getting that or what boy
look at that beautiful tree and what is
it it's like a little they got a little
ham kind of medallion a little coupled
aliens of pork right there and then they
got that they put a egg on it and god
damn that egg looks like a I mean it
looks like a damn little just a little
tit bra looks like a little protein
titty and they just set it right on
there and then they put a hollandaise on
that thing right I mean in that strong
hollandaise to like somebody just took
Holland off of a you know like like
somebody just took Holland off of a
globe and just outright on it at a
little stack you got going with that let
me google it real quick the thing is a
damn tasty header bra you put that thing
in your mouth and your mouth
turns into it damn it once more bra your
mouth will start to ovulate you feel my
cheeks Brian hey another angle dropping
I feel something dropping in my throat
like damn what was that I'm getting
fallopian in here this has got me
activated you take one bite of that my
pH balance changes I smell like I've
been playing basketball dude that's how
good that tree that breakfast treat is a
thing I'm making put on it and it looks
like if you read on the menu like oh who
eats this maybe um someone who's like a
captain in a war or something or
somebody like a woman with like a big
hat
you know we're somebody that's crying or
something a lot let me see
eggs some sauce meat ham and dalian and
it's on a bread sometime it's on a
biscuit or a little and you put it in
like a cut of bread Jesus man
oh sorry that's on you put it on a on
bread egg sauce ham a diatom bread what
is that misspelled sauce mmm oh
this is it I see a pattern right here
what is this
egg Benedict and that's who it is
egg Benedict man Oh egg Benedict but
he's being nicer now you feel me because
everybody's about to enjoy it you know
Eggs Benedict but uh but it's about to
be you know something everybody can
handle right now did you enjoy that clip
well you really would have enjoyed it if
he was watching on a TCL TV TCL is
America's fastest growing TV brand it's
so fast it's the Carl Lewis of
television brands it's that Florence
Griffith visual jointer
it's celebrating its fifth anniversary
from launching in the US markets I have
one of these at home and these suckers
are just I mean it's like having a Mona
Lisa on your wall that plays everything
you want follow TCL at TCL underscore
USA on Twitter and Instagram for more
details for more information about TCL
visit TCL usa.com
that's TCL usa.com